這裡是AI101,
全網最幽默的AI新聞,
日本聲優Kenjiro Tsuda打輸了AI仿生官司,
9月30日,
東京地方法院駁回他的請求。
可是同一份判決裡,
法院首次講明,
人的聲音也可能受到保護,
Tsuda輸了官司,
卻留下了首次司法判斷。
法院到底怎麼說?判決裡最關鍵的一句是,人的聲音跟肖像一樣,是個人、人格的象徵。
所以只要聲音有吸引顧客的力量
它帶來的商業價值
就可能受到公眾形象權保護
那蘇達的聲音有沒有這種稀客力
他配過咒術回戰的七海劍人
遊戲王的海馬賴人
那副辨識度極高的低沉嗓音
撐起他的職業形象和商業價值
就是他的招牌
但蘇達認為
有人盯上了這副嗓子
蘇達這邊指出
一個身份不明的TikTok賬號
從2024年7月到2025年9月
發了188支短片
旁白都是用生成式AI模仿他的聲音
這些片也不是發好玩的
蘇達主張
這個賬號拿他的名氣
換流量和錢
累計超過21萬名粉絲
每個月估計進賬50萬到75萬日元
不過這些數字是原告方的主張
不是法院認定的
那聲音到底像不像
兩邊講的完全相反
蘇達拿出音響分析
說兩者高度相似
TikTok的營運公司否認侵權
說那只是第三方聲音
訓練出來的普通男性聲音
據報道
上傳者還說AI用的是朋友的聲音
可是還沒有等法院回答像不像
賬號就先不見了
官司還在打
上傳者就在2026年5月
把賬號刪除
那些影片也跟著消失
也因為影片消失
官司就這樣輸了
Suda提出的是刪除影片的請求
被告是TikTok的營運公司
不是匿名上傳者
影片已經不在
平臺沒有東西可以刪
所以法院駁回
換句話說
法院沒有回答聲音像不像
也沒有認定這188支騙親權
更沒有判平臺賠償
法院承認的是
聲音原則上可以受到保護
蘇打先前也曾撲空
據多個報道
他申請公開發文者資料
東京地院也下令提供
可是連線記錄送到業者手上時
已經過了保存期限
先前程序沒能鎖定上傳者
這次則是刪除標的在判決前消失
同樣的難題
日本政府也在處理
法務省從今年4月到7月
開了5次會議
8月公佈報告
聲音靠現有的公眾形象權和人格利益
就能受到保護
這是對現行法的解讀
不是新定一部聲音權法
政府這樣解讀
那聲音的主人自己怎麼想
日本排憂聯合說
聲音是人格 尊嚴 信用和職業人生的一部分
一項國內服務的調查裡
48名實驗者
沒有任何一個人
同意自己的聲音被拿去用
所以回到蘇達身上
最矛盾的就在這裡
他贏了原則
卻沒有拿到實際救濟
要不要上訴
也還沒有公開決定
證據會過期
帳號能刪除
內容一下就消失
法律雖然開始追AI
卻總是慢一步
追蹤AI101
不錯過AI圈的最新消息